you've been selected for a mission which
you are not to discuss with anyone
outside of this room we are engaged in a
war with the Soviet Union this word is
not for the moment involve men-at-arms
it involves information something
important has come up we've got a Soviet
spy but there's a wrinkle you got us
five pilot
or the head full of classified
information the Russians got their man
back Corey cracks we want you to
negotiate the swap I'm an Insurance
lawyer I'm not sure I want to pick that
up are you good at what you do this will
be a first for the both of us you should
be careful I'm talking to you about the
security of your country why aren't we
hanging him you're asking me to violate
the Constitution do you know how people
will look at us the family of a man
trying to free a traitor everyone
deserves a defense every person matters
where do they want this negotiation East
Berlin just tell me that you're not
gonna be in any danger I don't even care
if it's the truth give me something to
hold on to
we need to have the conversation our
governments can't people in my country
consider this inept oh you can call it
what you want let's be clear nobody is
safe we're in a battle for civilization
the Constitution that's what makes us
Americans shouldn't we show our enemy
who we are things have started to fall
apart this your position of your
governments we do any outcome here or
I'm not either detained or shot do we
need to worry about you what's the move
and you don't know what the game is next
mistake our countries make could be the
last one
you